no i uh that china one
you know i know she's a she's got other
problems but but that video went
you know people got really upset about
it especially when they find out she was
13 and all that
yeah but that's real [ __ ] though yeah
look how great you look thank you
i i came i got ready and i was like i'm
gonna i'm gonna really
show out today yeah you did it right
no you're a smart girl thank you you're
one of the few i would say is
really like when you're talking yeah i'm
a professional when you told me you're
making money it's like of course you are
because you're smarter than the race
yeah i mean i mean
i'm not gonna say that
drug addicts are just stupid people but
it's just um
a lot of these girls they don't have
goals like
before they were prostitutes they
genuinely
didn't have goals they genuinely were
just
like settlers and i've just never
been that type of person by nature you
know like
like i said in my last video i wanted to
be top-notch
things like i didn't want to be a
mediocre person in society
yeah mediocre bores the hell out of me
the only thing that interested me is
something extraordinary yeah exactly
like maybe you are similar that way and
it's it's
yeah anything other than great is yeah
if you're gonna do something
you know do it right and do it
even if it's something like prostitution
yeah do it do it in a great way
be the best that you could be so you
were telling me off camera that now
you're you're working other
areas other than yes other than the
streets
i've been starting to work the casinos
and i've really been learning the power
of conversation
and how you just receive
a lot more money through conversation
than sex in a like an
outrageous way yeah you know and i just
feel like
every prostitute should learn this and
get to that level because the streets
is depressing and it can just really
bring
you down like mentally
emotionally just in a whole bunch of
ways but if you ever just like
dab into the casinos and then you just
like really start to see
that you're just worth so much more
than what you're used to so in the
casinos these are in las vegas
yeah you'll encounter a an older man i
assume who
likes the company of a beautiful young
girl yeah and you guys will
strike up a conversation yeah and it and
it's not
sexually related it's just having your
[Music]
your company yeah it's just company it's
conversation
and it's like you know you're a
beautiful young girl why would he not
want you know he wants to treat you like
a lady you know a lot of these guys they
want to like
feel like they have a girlfriend and
you know a lot of girls that are
prostitutes they'll be like oh i don't
do gfb
and nah i don't do that and i don't
either i don't do the bareback or none
of that weird [ __ ]
but gfb isn't necessarily that weird
[ __ ]
it's um it's just
it's like sugar baby type of thing for
those who don't know gfe
is it's a fantasy it's a it's
selling gfp stands for what girl
girlfriend experience
and and like girls are they they like
translate that into like bareback
and like kissing and all types of like
weird [ __ ] that you shouldn't do with
the trick
and that's not necessarily what it is
but i thought it
would mean is just like you're more like
you're interacting as a boyfriend
girlfriend right you're having
conversations you're talking about
movies you're doing whatever you're
doing right
and and that's more that's more
compensation for the girl
in the long run without getting naked
right because i mean a man
the woman who has his interests
like genuinely is always going to be
more interesting than the girl that he
just got a nut off on
you know that works with anybody yeah
you lose respect right away
so you're making money yes you're one of
the very few
no you know we all make money it's just
what you do with your money
yeah i guess that's it yeah what are
most of the girls doing with their money
um i mean you know
smoking smoking some weed getting their
little x pills you know
getting a little alcohol getting their
little outfits
you know normal stuff because
when you're on the streets and you just
see
fig and like you know track [ __ ]
you're just it's like a never-ending
cycle
and if you never see anything that's
like higher class or the finer things in
life
you just think like oh i'll go out here
and make it again
you know it's a lifestyle and [ __ ] but
that [ __ ] really
isn't a lifestyle it's just a trap
and you've learned this through your own
investigation or
somebody turned you off yeah like
through my own investigation
you're a very resourceful young lady
yeah i mean
as you explained last time i've always
felt like i
was a special person not even like on no
cocky [ __ ] honestly
because i remember when i first moved to
la
i was 17 and i was walking down
hollywood boulevard
and this producer they were like
recording something
and he was telling me he was like you're
so beautiful and i was like oh my god
like
he's a whole hollywood producer and he's
telling me i'm beautiful and that's
always stuck with me and i felt like
i could do anything i want with my
beauty i have the power to take over the
world
you do it's great yeah
that's what it takes to yeah thrive in
life
isn't it yeah it's more like confidence
within
than than on the outside what i've seen
is with it with all the people i
interview so many of them
when an opportunity to really get their
lives straight or get get ahead or make
a lot of money or do
some job opportunity or anything they'll
sabotage it
yeah they won't be able to accept it
they'll they'll flake on it they'll
resist it somehow they'll
they'll do something to ruin it
yeah and do you think like let's say
prince charming came along at one of the
casinos you're at and said hey i just
he really likes you and what if you
really liked him and all of a sudden you
guys like click
and he's wealthy and wants you to stop
doing this would you actually go along
with that or you think well
you know that i honestly feel like i
would never
marry somebody that i
clearly have the intentions to
extort but
um good for you but um
i would definitely have a very close
relationship with them
you know maybe figure out a
angle that we could both come out of but
i'm just too much of a genuine person
to do that yeah
do you actually do do you want to fall
in love and have kids one day and get
out of the business of course
of course i was watching like the little
other team so yeah i was watching the
other interview with the
the pimp and the hoe together the little
trio thing
um they were nice um but you were like
you can't make a hoe into a housewife
and i was like totally
relate where i have a stuttering problem
i was relating to what she was saying
when she was like
i could be a housewife to the certain
person
and yeah that's how i feel too she's a
she's a dream girl for the right guy
she is everyone is yeah that's what
makes it we'll go around
yeah yeah you know everybody
um everybody has a somebody
you know so are you still in love um
sure sure
so do you last time you didn't answer do
you have a pimp
um i mean i i prefer not to i
i kind of like to keep that personal
okay okay well i won't
second time i'll i'll stop asking okay
what is your definition of a pimp um
because there's so many different styles
of
these guys it's a man who comes into a
lady of
the night's life and he makes her better
simply but there's there's many
different styles there's the guys who
are no there's no style if you don't
make her better then you're not a pimp
period so what do you call these guys
that are like just street thugs that are
just
hustlers what do you call them how high
slurs oh that's such a great term
thank you that's a great term i think
i'll use that from now on because
because it's not right to call all these
tennis shoes
pimps because they're just they're so
different the reason i use that term is
because
they're doing the same thing they're
taking advantage of women that do this
for
work and they're keeping their money and
their
yeah they're not here for the lifestyle
it's all a hustle
in their eyes hoe hustlers mm-hmm that's
great exactly
so how much money will you make in a
casino as opposed to like on the street
the street you'll make what like seven
eight and i'm in the casino you'll make
what
like 18. you have the possibility to
make like two bands
that's great yeah i see why you're doing
it
i just started vegas so i'm still
you know getting into swings i'm
i'm supposed to go like next week
and then i'm gonna go to miami i've
never been to miami before so that'll be
a trip
for sure and what about drugs
drugs um no drugs i've been
i am an addict myself
um i've been struggling with it for
about a year now
i um started to like party
with my tricks for like more money
because they will pay you more money
and i just got addicted i got addicted
to drugs
and it has been a major problem in my
life
but it's an everyday struggle i'm gonna
be honest it's like i wake up
every day and i'm like i'm not going to
get high today
i'm just not gonna do it because i met a
girl about
two weeks ago and she was like
i was like do you want to ride and i
gave her a ride and she was like i'm on
my way to this program
and i was like okay what's the program
and she's like it's a rehab
i've been smoking crystal for 22 years
and i was just looking at her and i
could tell that she was really beautiful
at a certain point in time and the way
that she was talking
just reminded me of myself in a lot of
ways
and i was just telling myself i was like
you just need to stop like
don't do any you know relapses or
nothing that can sabotage your future
because
it's just it's a never-ending cycle it's
like really hell you know
being addicted to something
i've seen a lot i've come into contact
with a lot of um
signs i feel like that are just telling
me to stop
doing drugs yeah it can ruin your life
it can ruin your life
and it's like relapses you know you tell
yourself like oh
i'm just gonna you know you know and
it's hard for me because
i do it and then i have to like
literally go into my life and
i have to act normal around the people
that i love it's not like i have a binge
and i go off for days like no
i get high and i have to go back home
with the people that i love and care
about and act normal
so it's really hard for me
so i just decided to just say [ __ ] it
and to just
you know just think about those people
that
i came into contact with because i don't
wanna i don't wanna
be that how many of the
tricks and how many of the girls that do
this kind of work you think are
addicted or using heavily i feel like a
lot a lot of girls definitely
get high i mean i wouldn't say that they
use like as
hard drugs as like crystal
but they definitely do like x pills and
all of that [ __ ]
um it's hard to stay sober
when you're a prostitute i understand
that
but i would strongly encourage
you know all the girls to just stop you
know smoke weed or whatever but all the
other stuff that you say
makes you more looser to work it's just
it's not good for you in the long run
because your body is depending on that
do you find you get depressed doing this
no i don't yeah i answered that last
time you said no
yeah i mean i can't imagine you wouldn't
like
i would be depressed for the first time
yeah
it's not depressing it's not depressing
um
if you if you feel like you you're
working for something
yeah would it be possible for you to
have a relationship with a man a real
a love relationship with somebody while
you're doing this on the side
no i don't think so either i don't think
so because i
um even when i was like a normal girl i
had a boyfriend and stuff and
we were poor we were like really poor
like i was sleeping in his car with him
i was a minor and
um we were really poor like
like i would count corn quarters and
think that i was balling
if i had like five dollars in quarters
like i was very poor
but i always had you know a little bit
of sex appeal
so i would get what i wanted from men i
would be like you know i'm hungry or
this this and that and it would just be
little little acts of prostitution
here and there but like i wouldn't [ __ ]
them or anything but
when i think about it now it's you know
it's a little bit
it's a dab a prostitution and he would
get mad at me
and he would be like you're a [ __ ] and
you're a [ __ ] and there's this and that
because you're flirting with guys yeah
because i'm flirting with guys to get
what i want out of them
and i just feel like i'll always do that
i'm always going to do that
you're a flirtatious girl yeah
yeah last time like i just
i covered my you know drug problem real
quick because last time i was a little
scared to bring it up
but then i was like you know [ __ ] it
like i'm going to be honest
about me and i'm just going to tell the
truth because it's just like i have
nothing to be ashamed of because
i'm trying to overcome my problems
honestly there's nothing wrong with
that being honest i think is is the key
to overcoming your things
yeah i think yeah the crack addict that
i've done a couple interviews with
he's he's laying it all out everyone
loves him because he's like the most
honest person on my channel
and there's you know it makes you very
likable yeah
yeah i've had a few people like after my
interview they've been like oh
like i heard it and i was like i really
liked it and i was like oh thank you it
was i was really
nervous to do it because i thought
people were going to judge me but then
they were like wow you were like
honest and that [ __ ] was deep well the
key the key to being judged
harshly or positively is i think how
honest
right when they come in here you know if
you're honest and just lay it all out
as patrick did i mean his the comments
on his video are yeah
are unanimously really good he's the
best yeah i watched the whole thing and
i was i was like
i was really relating when he was like
it's frustrating that my drug addiction
is like my
biggest flaw in life
you know like i could tell that he was
like
a smart guy and that and society
like he's seen as you know like an
overwhelmed all-american guy but he just
has that addiction problem i really feel
like it's like a gene
thing with some people yeah i can really
relate it's complicated because it's
genetics it's also the trauma you go
through as a child
right it's it's your circumstances you
know sometimes
you're broke and you just need to
survive somehow and
yeah then you end up doing this kind of
work and that requires maybe you end up
playing around with these drugs and then
you get addicted yeah so many different
ways
yeah how does karma work into your life
um karma karma's a good question for all
these
people yeah i like i said i was watching
some earlier
and you were like you know you sleep
with all these guys
and i feel like
that is on them like you know you have a
wife at home
and you're kind of honestly it's on both
of you
i mean you can't you can't just say it's
all him i mean yeah
i mean it is on me because i'm i'm using
vanity
it takes two to tango so i guess
you know but
i mean i would never heard a fly like
i'm not i'm not a sinister person
i'm not doing this to be sinister and
he's trying to survive
yeah but but i mean you know in god's
eyes he's probably like come on [ __ ]
you know what's going on
but i'm not religious but what god would
say is that he wants you to do better
for yourself
yeah do something where you're loving
yourself more and this is probably the
most not not the most
yeah you know i think i'd rather be like
you know something
more nicer like a model or something
chic but it is what it is you know i
work my way up there
through time sometimes if you treat
yourself
as if you were somebody you really
respect a lot
you can pick whoever that is a hero or
or somebody in your imagination or god
or whoever jesus whatever
if you imagine yourself as being that
person
and treat yourself that way then you're
treating yourself with the utmost
respect
yeah and you're doing all the right
things for yourself and all of a sudden
everything kind of falls into place
beautifully
because you're not cutting corners
you're not just like cheating this night
or this guy or this whatever
just so you can make some buck to feed
yourself but you're you're treating
yourself as if you
truly respect yourself yeah and then
then all of a sudden this type of work
wouldn't really fit into that
yeah because you would never want your
grandmother let's say your grandmother
you wouldn't want your grandmother to do
this kind of work
i wouldn't i wouldn't even like um want
my friends to do this
that's what i'm saying so you treat
yourself as if you are your grandmother
at 20 years old or
or one of your friends or somebody that
you really care about
yeah but that's some deep [ __ ] life is
deep
you can't pretend it's not a lot of
people don't like to take it seriously
and that's that's how they get into
trouble
yeah they think they can just like not
look at that stuff and then it
creeps up and next you know you're
you're in a jam
yeah and you're smart enough to figure
this out
i know i know he's my girl
but i'm not judging i think what you're
you know you're doing it the right way
and you're making money and that's great
and you don't look like you're in
trouble
i'm definitely not in trouble you're not
getting beaten up definitely not
no bruises around here you haven't had
any bad experiences right
not yet not since um not since i've seen
you
just those two stories and um
since then it does happen though yeah it
does happen
it happens all the time
all the time
talk to your family i haven't really
been talking to my family as much
um my sister
me and her are having
we're having some disagreements
because she wants to enter the game and
um
i try to give her advice on how to do it
the correct way and she just doesn't
really want to listen to me
so i just feel like then just don't do
it
if you don't want to do it the right way
it's like i'm your little sister but
when it comes to this
like you need to take heed of what i'm
saying
so we're kind of you know arguing and
with that and then with my dad
he um i feel like he's acting really
weird towards me
because he's not my real dad you know
he's my adoptive dad
and he's just acting a little strange
but any dad or step dad or whatever is
not going to be
pleased with the situation that you're
in well he's actually um
like i'll send him pictures and he'll be
like you look
gorgeous and just he'll just say really
weird things
so i haven't really been texting him
that much because
i don't know if i said in my last video
he was like a little abusive during my
childhood
and i kind of just got an eye opener
from a close friend
that he is just on weird [ __ ]
so i was like okay let me just kind of
back away
because i was kind of trying to create a
relationship with him
like he was my dad but he's really not
because
of what he did to me when i was a child
and
you know what did he do when you were
young he just used to like
strip me naked and just what me
like all the time and when i was like 11
12. so
um when i sent him pictures now
and he's like you're gorgeous and all of
this
it's like kind of awkward because
you know he just notices things that
father shouldn't notice
like like he asked me if i was pregnant
one time
and i just feel like when i send him
stuff he just like looks at it in a way
that he shouldn't be looking at it
you can sense that yeah yeah i feel like
he's just being um
you know weird and do you think maybe
you're addicted to this this
lifestyle um i know you've only been
doing it a year or so
no i don't think i'm i mean yes i know
yeah yes and no means yes
yeah i think it's got to be very
addicting because any other life any
other job has got to be
i mean i couldn't be a square i could
never be a square
ever like ever i don't think i could
ever be a square
once you've done this it's going to be
hard to go back to it's hard i mean i
could never be with like a man
who is just not um
like if you have like trick tendencies
i can't be with you period point blank
and if you can't accept that i'm gonna
go to a grocery store and i might
meet a nice man then i can't be with you
you know so he's supposed to accept that
you've had this pass but you can't
accept that he might have had a similar
one
i mean
that's evil the way did she put it um
it's not evil it's just a fact
you know you're you're saying he can't
do anything wrong
i mean he's never going to be able to
really accept me because he's
always gonna look at me like i'm just
like oh yeah my wife used to be
he's always gonna feel like he saved me
or something
you know because i've met guys who are
like oh yeah
my wife used to be a prostitute and it's
just like they feel like
they saved her in some type of way
and i don't i think it's human nature to
kind of want to do that for people
i think it's human nature to want to
save damsel's
damsels in distress of course
of course especially when they're
particularly attractive i find that
the comments on the attractive girls get
10 times 100 times more
people that want to help then definitely
i mean i can relate
i can relate
so how many years do you think you'll be
doing this um just
like a couple more i honestly if it
doesn't
i mean i know it'll work out it'll work
out i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get a few um things out of
this but
i would just stop cold turkey
if i was like getting like pressing that
30 line even like 26 line
because that's a little in terms of age
yeah that's pushing it
it's pushing it
that's just me that's just my thinking i
feel like if you're 25 and older you
should not be
an escort or prostitute or any type of
all right royalty well thank you so much
for sharing your story again coming in
again
thank you for having me i wish you the
best of luck be careful in vegas
thank you i hope you save lots of money
thank you
and i hope you get out one day thank you
so much
thank you okay